can you think of a single person whose
career would literally be over
if they had slept with someone or if
they came out to have a boyfriend or
something
because i can't yeah like you'd be you'd
get clowned on you'd lose subscribers
you'd lose viewers maybe because you
wouldn't actually lose your thing but
yeah you would be clowned on pretty yeah
the only person i can think of is like
pokemon yeah
that's like i didn't know whether to
bring that up or not but i mean
if we're talking about the most recent
thing right but but even then like what
she's getting is
nowhere near as bad as what some of
these like idols yeah musicians are
getting like if
if pokeman came out today and she was
like hey i have a boyfriend
she'd probably get less attention than
she does now but her career wouldn't be
over no you should still
easily have a career i think it i
thought it was confirmed right it was
yeah i think it was i i i don't know
i think the whole i think the whole
point was it's like well yeah of course
she's human she's going to have a
relationship
right and not everyone needs to know
that like that's fine exactly it's
it's her choice if she wants to hire
yeah exactly those seems man they've
yeah
they're just like dude when youtubers
make videos like where they're in like a
one-week
week relationship like we're together
it's like
i get like real like [ __ ] it oh yeah
yeah yeah i think like it says so much
about you
like to me it's like at least wait a
couple of months man like
try and figure it out it's like a real
thing it feels like i don't know
not to be like to say it but it's kind
of like a like oh
i'm going to have sex for the first time
i should announce it to the world yeah
it is it is
i feel like it says a lot about your
maturity level to do that i think
like and it's normally i wouldn't
associate with a youtuber who does that
i i feel like it's also
just a lot of people can do it for
clickbait as well they do they do
oh yeah but either way normally there's
no good like connotation that comes
along with
doing that right there's normally no
nothing good that's coming sure they're
probably very happy i'm glad for them
but like
you know let's be honest at our age
which most of the youtubers are
most of the relationships fail when
they're that early yeah exactly most of
them do yeah
yeah again like it's fine if you want to
yeah it's fine if you want to come out
but like
yeah as you said if i watch like a if i
watch like a coming out kind of video
and it's just like
we're together now i met her last week
i'm just like
all right i'm counting down the days of
the week
video right you'd be together for like a
few weeks months right get comfortable
yeah like in your head why would you not
be like
feel like you're secure before you make
it it's like do you introduce
this girl to your parents a week after
you just started dating yeah
well you're not you know like she was
probably introducing it to their
audience before their parents yeah
bro bro backwards backwards come on
because i know aki and i waited about
three months yeah you probably felt
pretty comfortable yeah because we were
because we you know we wanted to enjoy
our time together just like privately
yeah and we did and then we were like
okay you know now if we want to actually
do more stuff now
you know instead of like hiding about it
then i think now is the right time like
yeah we're comfortable now
especially you get it out position it's
kind of kind of forced to tell
people yeah exactly you're gonna be
together i can't hide that [ __ ]
right both of you like posting
constantly and
yeah both of you are together and a lot
of people yeah exactly we're going to
connect the dots
like oh is she just going to go hang out
with him is that how it is really
nah but yeah both of you and youtuber
relationships which are normally
uh you know the landmine waiting to ha
to just go off
yeah what are you saying
i mean normally at least you guys are in
the clear now i feel like you've got to
the stage where it's like all right it's
mega seriously yeah yeah
you're [ __ ] married get out of your
sight yeah [ __ ] simpsons
[ __ ] side of these [ __ ] happy
people around me
but like when you're like i dude
especially at
my size now i'd be like i'd be way too
scared to date another youtuber that's
like
no i mean i get that i mean for me with
sydney it's it's kind of like it's it's
kind of a bit
a bit different yeah because she i mean
she has been on youtube for a very long
time but
i wouldn't really call her like a
youtuber where she does this as a job
she's like kind of grown pretty recently
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah and i
mean i we started dating when i wasn't
this was before i came back to do
youtube full-time anyway so we've been
dating for like a very long time like a
good five six years
but yeah i remember seeing your video
like was it nerve-wracking for you guys
coming out to be like hey yeah we're a
youtuber yeah definitely
what was the reaction like i mean the
reaction was mostly really really
positive
um thank god uh but i remember
i remember aki losing a very significant
portion of a male audience
and i lost a very significant portion of
my female audience
so what kind of numbers are we talking
about like i probably
i don't know for like when before we
came out i think i had
uh i think i had like a 60 40
female-to-male ratio
right which i was like wow okay i
thought more males would be insane but
then the moment i came out i think that
dropped by like
10-15 at least it was a really
significant number
and same thing with aki as well it's
about at least a 10-15 drop but we kind
of expected that
yeah um because i i like we'd had been
to conventions enough times and we saw
a lot of people were speculating yeah
yeah we saw a lot of people were
speculating right
i think i remember watching your like ax
vlog and then people had saw that you
had like a hickey
oh yeah i was like oh it's joey
getting it on here yeah
we're not proud of that i knew i knew
aki followed
him was like god damn it jerry you left
that yeah well we're not proud of that
that's all right that's all right we
were young we were young yeah he's like
that's whatever
it's cute it's whatever yeah whatever
it's cute when we look back on it it's
fine but um
yeah it must have been stressful back
then where people were just speculating
every like enhance enhance
enhance csi people
is that a hickey or a project
check for fingerprints someone's in that
darkroom
yeah i don't know but like i think it
was nerve-wracking for the both of us
because it was the first time that we'd
ever had to make a video like that yeah
and
and we knew we had to make a video like
that right yeah eventually we weren't
going to hide it for the rest of our
career
so i think it was stressful at the time
and we and you can see it in our coming
out videos that we're very like
you know nervous and like yeah yeah
we're kind of together now kind of thing
but
at the same time like after that video
went out i was just like oh thank god
now i don't have to [ __ ]
hide about it as well
a lot of support oh yeah there was a lot
of sport i had a lot of [ __ ] like
youtubers
approach me who had never spoken to me i
remember god
[ __ ] tweeted out so this was this was
i think our first interaction since that
time we thought we hated it yeah
it was the first interaction like it was
the first interaction on twitter where
like dart was like congrats to anime man
archiders for game together and i was
just like
oh my gosh yeah i'm just like oh my god
he doesn't hate me
yeah i think he likes me guys no we i
had a lot of antitubers uh tweet at us
yeah being like yeah the two biggest and
youtubers are together and
it was like a really big deal i'm like
it's not that big a deal guys we just
we're just getting together
yeah it's all good but no we were really
happy about it because again like we
were a little bit worried about like
maybe there might be some kind of hidden
you know thing that put us in some kind
of a negative light but
no it all came out really fast because i
remember watching that video and i
remember thinking man they they
i think they definitely approach this
the right way because and everyone knew
you if you were dating you
this was something that you would have
to address sooner or later yeah of
course you're both big personalities on
the platform yeah i think you definitely
went about it the right way
and i remember just wanting to
congratulate you because i i know the
trouble is going through a long-distance
relationship as well
oh yeah sydney man that that shit's
tough yeah
you know tell me about it we were in a
long distance for two and a half years
man
yeah i don't know i like your brain
can't handle yeah
yeah because i was i was long distance
with sydney for like a good year or
something
and now that was like one of the hardest
years of my life did you when you were
like
still single online did you get messages
people like would you ever
do long long distance
are you available for a long distance
like what kind of kind of time zone
difference is it
like i'm like i'm like just [ __ ] say
it just yeah
yeah like what do you expect me to say
it's like if it's less than eight hours
then it's doable but any more than that
bro
it's like like if i ever like when i
used to live stream doing likes
like when you know us doing sebastian
stuff the most common thing that i would
often get is like
there's a yeah long distance what's your
thoughts on that connor what are your
thoughts on that you're dating anyone by
the way you know yeah they don't just
say it they're just like
are you are you perhaps considering the
possibility yeah or they'll say uh
what's your uh ideal partner like
just just want just just i got that a
lot i got that a lot when i was doing
panelists
i'm not trying to say that i'm like a
gigger chad and everyone just can't help
themselves but you know you just get
people who
like obviously i mean i think you can
say that as the 93 percent
yeah you can say that i mean you should
expect that yeah you can i mean
when you okay when there's thousands of
subscribers there's gonna be like one or
two of them that are interested in yeah
yeah
that are gonna try and you know see what
ways they can pursue that yeah yeah from
a formally written email which is many
times
or they'll do a not so subtle donation
what is the logistics of us putting up
together in this in this long-distance
relationship
what i gotta do is i gotta some episode
i need to bring a presentation of all
the different ways people have tried to
hit on
like i gotta please it's like it's a
powerpoint presentation
the most interesting ways it's happening
i'm not trying to do anything i'm just
trying to say it's really [ __ ]
interesting
the way that people try to like get in
there top 10 confessions in anime
dude it's so interesting when you
realize it the way because like there's
like routes in their mind like
yeah yeah that's right i'm gonna go like
okay i'm gonna direct her out the
curveball round
okay it's like a [ __ ] visual novel
there's like
levels of difficulty there's like
youtube comment impossible for him to
educate me
to like level 99 to like donate ten
thousand dollars so he cannot ignore me
like it's like and there's so many in
between it's so funny oh yeah i mean if
you guys are interested in that let us
know let us know down below if you want
to hear the power
i'll actually i'll be interested i will
legit prepare a powerpoint presentation
for something right yeah i'll do it i'll
please oh my god